We can bring you through the instructions.
We can start now. I'm going to press play, space here to play, and then you can pause anytime.
You can read your own performance.
Wait, I just want to confirm here. Do I narrate what I'm thinking?
What you're thinking, what you're feeling, during that same exact moment.
Okay, thank you.
So, this moment, I felt like my beginning move wasn't as strong as usual.
And so I tried to make more power towards the front.
For this section, I was trying to pay attention to the sidekick.
Just making sure I wouldn't lose my balance and such.
That part there, I saw my foot somewhat tilt as I was losing balance.
And then this part, just make sure to stay strong throughout the end.
Stay consistent, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.